lever la main si vous habitez au canada
laissez votre main levée si vous êtes
nés à l'extérieur du canada
vous pouvez baisser votre main
alors que les personnes qui ont laissé
leur main levée le savent bien
l'immigration
crée un moment charnière dans notre hub
il ya l'avant et l'après
l'avant nous fera comprendre qu'ils ont
ni nos racines et pourquoi on est parti
elle après nous amène à réfléchir sur
notre relation
avec notre nouvelle terre d'accueil
alors voilà pour moi l'avancé l'iran
on né en 1981 à téhéran
une immense capital de plus de quatre
millions d'habitants
bordé au nord de montagnes colossales
que je vois parfaitement des fenêtres de
ma maison
il y a toujours ses odeurs de pain qu on
fait cuire dans des fours sous terre
devant vous du bon pain frais et chaud
j'ai 6 ans je suis dans ma maison à
téhéran
une journée chaude comme il peut faire
chaud en iran
mes parents sont devant la fenêtre moi
je suis assise sur leur lit et je joue
avec mes jouets
jeux pour soudainement mes parents qui
commencent à s'agiter
il vient d'apercevoir une jeune fille
probablement une opposante au régime
pris en filature par un gardien de la
révolution
elle essaie de s'enfuir dans une ruelle
centraux d'issue
j'entends et je vois encore aujourd'hui
ma mère
raconté à mon père la scène qui se
déroule devant elle
regarde il va la tuer
et son temps devient de plus en plus
alarmé affolé
regarde il attire elle est tombée
et en prononçant ces mots ma mère tombe
dans les pommes
je suis terrifiée je sais pas si ma mère
est morte mon père est en train de la
réanimer j'ai personne vers qui me
tourner nulle part où aller je regarde
autour de moi je vois le placard de mon
père et je vais me cacher dans son
manteau
après un temps qui m'a paru comme une
éternité
les parents sont finalement venus
trouver
les années plus tard
mon père m'a dit que le gardien de
révolution qui habitués cette jeune
fille devant chez nous avait levé les
bras comme ça
en signe de victoire
comme dans un match de foot
quand on marque un but
j'avais cinq ans quand la révolution
iranienne a commencé j'aime bien dire
que moi aussi j'ai fait la révolution
comme des millions d'iraniens mais sur
les épaules de mon papa
j'ai le souvenir d'une période
d'euphorie
des grandes manifestations de rue des
jeunes des étudiants des gens qui
voulaient changer les choses qui inspire
et à une vie meilleure
par solidarité les habitants téhéran les
mêmes leurs portes ouvertes pour qu'on
aille se réfugier dans leur cour leur
jardin quand on était poursuivi par
l'armée du roi d'iran le chat
par nommant les taxis pouvait même
transporter des gens gratuitement
d'autres distribuent de la nourriture
dans les rues
mais après l'euphorie il ya eu la
déception
et la répression
et puis comment ça c'est une guerre avec
l'irak
les bombardements le ciren le champ de
mines la guerre de tranchées
guerre quoi
d'ailleurs il ya toujours une guerre
quelque part
cette guerre dont on se rappelle même
plus ni pourquoi ni comment elle avait
commencé mais qui a fait plus de huit
cent mille morts
et beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de dégâts
c'est aussi cette guerre qui nous a fait
quitter notre terre natale
notre chez nous
pour moi c'est un moment difficile de
séparation
mon déracinement
quand on est arrivés en france je
parlais pas un mot de français
on a commencé à se pratiquer en faisant
des phrases simples et courtes
bonjour je m'appelle sherazade j'ai 11
ans et j'habite à poitiers
évidemment si vous connaissez le mot
personnes vous savez que tout cet
exercice a très vite tourné en
taquineries il faut dire que tout le
monde dans ma famille parlait un peu le
français mes parents avaient vécu à
paris quand il était jeune et mon frère
avait étudié le français en iran avant
la révolution d'ailleurs c'est mon frère
qui me taquiner il mit mit thijs moquer
de moi en train de mal à répondre aux
questions
quel âge as-tu je m'appelle sherazade
quel est ton nom g11
j'arrive à l'école en plein milieu de
l'année scolaire et j'ai tout de suite
embarqué dans le train
mon objectif était de tout apprendre par
coeur d'ailleurs j'étais très bonne pour
réciter de la poésie française dont je
comprenais plus de moi le sens
ma prof de français de l'époque avait
dit à mes parents et sage oublierai
jamais si j'ai une médaille à donner à
quelqu'un je la donnerai à votre vie
pour sa persévérance
avec le recul aujourd'hui je réalise
comme tout ça a été stressant angoissant
cette adaptation rapide à une nouvelle
terre d'accueil
d'ailleurs cette angoisse vous savez et
nous poursuit très longtemps après
moi je la ressens encore aujourd'hui
mon intuition d'enfants mais amené à
vouloir très vite tourner la page et me
fondre dans la masse
d'ailleurs c'est à cette époque que j'ai
commencé aussi à me dissocier des
aspects de mes origines
je n'aimais pas parler le persan en
public j'avais l'impression d'attirer
tous les regards sont moins
six regards dans lesquels je percevais
de la curiosité
mais aussi souvent du jugement
je voulais aussi parlé avec le même
accent que mon groupe ma nouvelle tribu
j'ai clairement cherché à me dissocier
de mon pays d'origine l'iran un pays
qu'on qualifiés de terroristes
intégristes
on peut dire que je me suis adapté en
niant une partie de qui j'étais
et d'où je viens
et d'ailleurs c'est l'un des regrets de
ma vie j'ai pas pu préserver ma langue
natale de personnes comme je l'aurais
souhaité même si je me débrouille bien
j'ai par la suite passer ma vie d'adulte
au québec hélas malgré bon les clichés
habituels sur l'accent les expressions
dit si le fait de devoir comprendre
l'émission télévisuelle la petite vie
parler la langue d'un nouveau pays
d'accueil c'est clairement un atout dans
ma nouvelle vie j'entame donc ma vie
d'adulte avec beaucoup d'espoir en plus
je parle français avec l'accent de
france du moins dans les débuts et quand
on me demande et une française j'ai dit
oui et c'est régler
ça avant que je dise mon nom
shérazade adib
est là vient toujours la question
d'après d'où viens-tu
honnêtement dans ma tête la réponse à
cette question n'est pas très clair
et à cette confusion vient se rajouter
les moments malesan qui me rappelle
toujours ma différence
comme cette dame dans une épicerie de
quartier qui me dit nous avons la
tourtière vous connaissez ça
évidemment les certainement pleins de
bonnes intentions mais elle sait pas que
ça fait déjà 25 ans que je suis au
québec
finalement on se rend compte qu'on a
beau parler la langue elle même être
très éduquée
l'intégration l'inclusion c'est un
effort et une adaptation continuelle
d'ailleurs c'est dans cette adaptation à
l'autre qu'on est amené aussi à cacher
des aspects de qui on est pour mieux
survivre
j'ai vraiment réalisé très tard dans ma
vie d'adulte en lisant sur ce concept
que je n'étais pas la seule à avoir
caché des aspects de mon identité
évidemment sent moins seul et moins
honteux
d'ailleurs ce concept de dissimulation
de l'identité et de plus en plus
documenté aujourd'hui on entend beaucoup
de témoignages de personnes qui comme
moins essayer de se dissocier de leurs
différences en changeant leur nom leur
comportement leur accent
en présence de l'autre
on appelle ça en anglais le code
switching changer de code
parce que changer de code s'ajuster
ajusté à loos ajustait à l'autre pour
être acceptée c'est aussi une façon de
se protéger
andreck aujourd'hui je prend pleinement
conscience des répercussions que ç'a eu
sur moi sur ma confiance en moi sur mon
estime de moi
parce que nier des aspects de qui on est
de nos origines de notre histoire
c'est quelque part aussi se diminuer soi
même
et puis vous savez il n'ya pas vraiment
de gagnant ici même que tout le monde y
perd incluant la société qui nous
accueillent si généreusement qui nous
dit bienvenue chez nous
et qui perd aussi à pas voir les
personnes dans leur entièreté
et maintenant pour revenir à la
thématique la conférence posons nous
cette question
si tout le monde y perd pourquoi pas
essayer de changer les choses
j'aimerais d'abord dire aux personnes
qui sont nés ici
que vous avez pas besoin d'avoir quitté
votre pays natal pour vous sentir
étranger
que vous pouvez le sentir à travers
toutes sortes différence
que vous soyez un homme qui vit dans le
corps d'une femme issue de la deuxième
génération d'immigration timide neuro
atypique et j'en passe
si c'est votre cas vous êtes peut-être
même reconnu dans mon histoire
j'aimerais vous dire que pour moi
l'inclusion c'est une danse à deux
ne jugez pas l'autre mettez-vous à sa
place
parce que l'harmonie ne peut être créé
que lorsqu un véritable échange est
engagé
et cet échange implique aussi de
reconnaître ce que l'on peut nous amener
de par ses différentes expériences
donc voir l'autre reconnaît sa valeur
ses efforts lui faire une vraie place et
l'accepter
j'aimerais ensuite dire aux personnes
qui ne sont pas nés ici
que peu importe la raison de votre
départ que ce soit la guerre le climat
la recherche d'une vie meilleure
notre véritable chez soi c'est aussi
notre territoire intérieur
ne l'abandonné pas derrière vous votre
histoire est importante et mérite d'être
écouté elle mérite d'être racontée peu
importe votre accent
votre parcours aux multiples
enracinement sont une source de richesse
qui mérite d'être exploité
aujourd'hui quelques quarante années
plus tard
j'aimerais accueillir avec bienveillance
l'enfant que j'étais et qui s'est caché
dans le placard
j'aimerais lui dire mme vien sort
n'est pas peur il y à une maille qui
t'attend
j'aime peut aussi croire que nous tous
ici quand soigner ici ou peint ce mât la
fois capable d'accueillir notre enfant
intérieur
est de trouver le courage de tendre la
main
vers celui des autres
merci
[Applaudissements]